Automatic simplification works especially well in situations
where the tests are also generated automatically.
If you have taken a testing class recently, you may have heard about fuzz test.
Fuzz testing is a technique where you generate random inputs for a program or an API.
It's a common testing method to see whether something breaks.
To show you how fuzz testing works, let's first write a fuzzer,
which is a function which generates such a random input.
So here's our fuzzer function.
We want to have a function that generates strings of up to 1023 characters
filled with regular printable ASCII symbols.
So first we determine the string length we'd like to have and for that, simply take a random number--
random.random returns a random number between 0 and 1 and multiply this with 1024,
so we get a length of up to 1023 characters.
And here we have a simple loop over the string length.
We generate a character which takes an arbitrary value between 32 and 128 by using
again the random function multiplied with 96 adding 32.
We add the character to the out string and return the out sting at the end.
Let us see what fuzzer produces--press on run and here we have
a non-string filled with random characters.
If we have a look at it again, we're going to get another random string, and here we go.
I think what happens if I take such a random string and paste it into a function that accepts
say a filename or an email address or a URL, all of these functions work well
even when confounded with seemingly totally random input.
In the age of the Internet, any input that is under control by a third parties can easily look like this,
and fuzz testing is indeed one of the attack vectors of people wanting to penetrate into your system.